hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and ah
[Music]
checking in on you
I'm just checking in on you just seeing
how you're doing how are you doing today
I hope you're doing better than me
because I'll tell you what I will [__]
ing do you what
I was all [__] Billy Blues the last
two days man I was just [__] sad
you know
maybe just get like you don't even know
why you're sad you've been burying it so
long
you don't even know what the sadness is
connected to wow I put this [__]
podcast on to feel better
where are you going with this
oh I'm going into the muck and the mire
the Maya
um yeah dude and I was I did something
that I never do I just sat in it
and kind of wrote it out tried to figure
it out as opposed to doing what I've
been doing my whole life which is like
I'll just go do stand up oh [__] go
play some drums I'll learn how to fly a
helicopter yeah that'll do it just just
think about other stuff
yeah
so
I don't know what it was just some sort
of leftover [__]
and uh it was one of those deals where I
still had my slippers on it one in the
afternoon
which is funny on two levels one that I
still had on slippers
at one in the afternoon and two that I
wear slippers and I do
I have the oldest [__] pair I don't
even know like you know I just every
time I think of throwing something else
I just picture all that [__] in the
[__] ocean I'm like where is this
gonna end up
in the ground
are out there in the water like why
should some porpoise have to deal with
my old slippers why do fish have to deal
with any mistakes that we make here on
land it's it's you know I understand
other animals
like cheetahs and pigeons and all of
that [__] it's just like you know you
share this with us
okay
you had the ability to overpower us and
kill us
back when we were in the caves and you
didn't do it you [__] blew it you had
your opportunity to put us to bed right
what did all the Predators do what did
they do
just like a bad football team they let
us hang around
and all of a sudden we were still there
in the fourth quarter
just sat there as we figured out fire ah
we'll get we'll get to killing those
[__] these uh prehistoric wildebeests
are too goddamn delicious and they let
us [__] hang around and now look at
us running wild
there's only one Predator left that can
take us out
and that's mother nature and she's been
sleeping on the couch for [__]
centuries and I think she's finally
starting to wake up
and we will see what happens so anyway
so I have slippers people
I don't know when I got him I don't know
why I had them and I was just sitting
there in bed being sad
I don't want to practice French I don't
want to play my draw I don't want to
[__] do anything I just stayed in it
and um
somewhere around 1 30.
I was just sitting there going like all
right
you know I'm never getting this day back
so this is what it's going to be why
don't we have a little Victory here
there is a bunch of [__] in your sock
drawer that is not socks why don't we
clear that out
and I started doing that and then I
moved on to my undo I started feeling
better
and I moved on to my underwear drawer I
got you know
I had those [__] some old boxes in
there you know with the the band starts
getting all like all bunched up and
wrinkled like it's had enough
had enough big meals you know it's done
the job
tells you junk long enough and just like
all right guys you know put me out to
pasture it's ready it's ready to retire
right like the great Tom Brady
um so [__] sifted through that
you know
and I don't know I just started feeling
better next thing you know I had a few
things to do started moving around or
something so I'm gonna kind of do a
combination of that
see if I can work my way through
whatever the [__] my problem is
um but I mean I'm not like you know
clinically depressed
you know like those people that can't
even get off the ground I I fortunately
don't have that and it's just like this
overwhelming like Melancholy every once
in a while it's like what am I doing I
don't know what am I doing
what the [__] am I doing what is this
all
what does it all mean right
I'll tell you what's hilarious
is my son woke me up this morning 701 in
the morning he could now get out of the
crib I got to put pillows all the way
around
his crib we have like a monitor so at
night when he goes to start doing it we
say hey hey you know we can talk to him
lay back down he goes okay
he's [__] he's at such a [__]
hilarious age he's hilarious
did I put him to bed the other night and
I said all right good night buddy and he
goes
he goes all right he goes he goes night
night sweetie
because that's what my wife says to him
he said good night sweetie it was
hilarious it was like he was breaking my
balls
all right there sugar right there sweet
tits I'll see you later [__] laughing
my ass off walking out of the room
um
so anyway talk about cheering you up
right so he came into the room this
morning
701 comes bursting in he should be in
bed for another half hour but now he
knows how to get out he also gets out of
his sleep sack he doesn't even have to
like unzip it it's like [__] Harry
Houdini I don't know if he separates one
of his little shoulders
oh Harry used I don't know how he gets
out of it but the bag is just sitting
there
like he the Sleep sack like he you know
took on a a different form
and just stepped out of it
you know like I got left behind or
something that's how it looks past fire
right next to it sleep sack on the
ground and he's in my room 701
and I hear the door open I'm like what
in God's name what's my daughter doing
up this early and I had to I hear that
dun dun
dun dun you know those little feet
running up to bed I'm like all right
my daughter does not walk like that and
I look open my one eye and look over
and he just goes hey Dad
like it was two in the afternoon
French toast
Dad Dad French toast and I'm like in a
little while buddy I'm still sleeping
and he goes oh
that's it now I'm up because they get
into bed no matter how big the bed is
they're going to be right on you pushing
their feet into you the whole time
breathing loudly so it's like all right
I guess we're up
and uh
I went downstairs and I started slinging
the French toast
um anyway
so that was my morning
um
took my daughter to school and all of
that and then I came home
and I was feeling the cold coming on so
I didn't go to the gym
and I was like all right you trying to
take time off bill because I was like oh
I don't have to go to the gym let me
turn it I'll go [__] do this I'll
[__] do that go no why don't you just
[__] actually try to relax
fight off this cold it's like all right
that's what I'm gonna do and I sat in
that bed and within 40 minutes I went
from completely denying my feelings to
being neck deep in whatever the [__] is
wrong with me and I'm just like how high
up is this gonna go
is my head going under what is going to
happen
and yeah that's it I sat there for three
and a half hours I watched um
I'd watch the Burt Reynolds movie with
my buddy the other night I watched
um Sharky's Machine which I loved when I
was a kid it came out when I was 13
years old and I went back and I saw that
so I was like all right I'm gonna watch
another Burt Reynolds movie how do you
lay off Burt Reynold now somebody else
was telling me that their favorite movie
that Burt Reynolds did was Hooper
so I was like I love that movie and I
saw it when I was a kid all right let me
go check that out
and uh uh I watched that one
um
you know Burt Reynolds Terry Bradshaw
how do you lay off that I will tell you
this though having watched
a lot of Burt Reynolds work
he was a really great actor
and I just feel like they didn't use
them
necessarily the right way all the time
you know what I mean they always had
them in these these sort of
like
comedies and stuff but I prefer them way
more in like Deliverance
Sharky's Machine
um
Boogie Nights I liked I I love that side
of them I mean believe me I love
Cannonball Run smoking the Bandit Hooper
no I still love those movies but I
really like
the ones where um you know when when
Sharky's Machine came out they asked
them what to move to describe the movie
and he called it Dirty Harry in Atlanta
so
um
you know and it's kind of the best
of Burt Reynolds where it's like
you get the humor you get the action but
then it's also like this really serious
story
and you get to see him like you know
doing like I don't know more like a
grounded roll rather than just driving
some car fast and [__] going over you
know doing the Dukes of Hazzard jumps
which I love don't get me wrong
um it's kind of funny that those movies
just kind of went away
like when was the last time there was a
good car movie
you know
like I was talking to a buddy of mine
about Burt Reynolds
and he had me die and laugh and talking
about like dude I wanted to be that guy
so bad like he was literally
like The Benchmark of what being a good
looking guy was for like this 10-year
period
and uh
I gotta tell you as a ginger
looking at Burt Reynolds it's going like
hey I ain't ever pulling that off
I mean who didn't want to [__] look
like that guy Jesus Christ
um
but I also think that's another thing
that kind of pulled me like into the
sadness going back to that time in my
life or whatever like all that you know
you know that weird shitty a childhood
where was like awesome because you
didn't have any bills and you were free
but then there's all the other [__]
attached to it or whatever I also like
what I do like about like when I I saw
Sharky's Machine and then I saw um
what's this what was the one I saw um
the Michael Mann movie Thief with James
Khan what I love about that early 80s
era is
it was such a bad era for American cars
and watching them try to get a cool car
for uh for the lead because that was a
big [__] deal back in the day what
kind of car is this guy gonna drive
um
was I felt equally as important as as
the the the actor you know what I mean
you know what did Steve mcgarrett Drive
you know in Hawaii 5-0 what's he gonna
drive all the way through the casino
movies the
um Bronx Tale what's Chaz palm and
Terry's character gonna drive here
that's 67
I think it was 66 or 67 Cadillac
that candy apple red just backing it
down the [__] Street oh my God
I mean it's just I mean I'm in I'm
[__] in
I wish they would do that more I wish
two two-tone paint
different colors and better Interiors
would come back
those infinite options I just saw a guy
had a [__] Dodge uh
Challenger I don't know what year it was
but it was [__] badass it had to get
the
the gas cap first of all it looked like
the gas cap alone looked like weighed
like [__] eight pounds and it was
sitting on top of the left rear quarter
panel
which I thought was badass I mean that's
to have it there is badass and then also
to have it behind the license plate
like that's what I remember for being a
kid when they were like running out of
gas and all of that allegedly running on
it was literally a gas shortage think
about that 50 years ago and everybody
was in a panic that they were going to
run out of gas and I was saying to my
grandfather there's going to be no gas
by the time I learned how to drive
and uh you know the speed limit kept
dropping the speed limit the speed limit
was gonna be like 35 miles an hour I
remember smoking his pipe going oh no
sure no never don't ever drop it down
I'll go
and he was right he called it a [__]
called it
maybe another reason for my sadness
uh that I fell into this week is because
there's something about that week
between that week off between the AFC
and NFC championship games and the Super
Bowl that reminds you
you know that there's there's only one
football game left it reminds you what
your weekends are going to be like this
weird thing
that happens for the rest of uh February
where you deal with no
um what the [__] is this thing doing
okay not now sorry not now it's these
goddamn [__] messages
you know what kills me about these
[__] computers and phones I mean I
can't make them do anything but if I
brush up against it there's like 20
commands come up
you know
like if it just sort of brush your
keyboard and your home screen all of a
sudden all four things go to the corner
like every window you had open you're
like how the [__] did I do that
it's like miniature golf you send it
through the windmill and it goes down
the screwy thing and it goes into the
hole he could never do it again
or maybe you could it's miniature golf
who's getting who
um
anyway but then you get March Madness
and then you get the uh the NHL NBA
playoffs or whatever
I don't know what does that say about me
that if I don't have sports
specifically football
then all of a sudden I am laying in bed
on a random Thursday with my slippers on
at 1 30 in the [__] afternoon
um all right let's stop being a Sad Sack
and let's [__] bring this around
let's bring it around all right it's the
first 10 days of the month so This Is
Where Oh Billy detox kicks in no cigars
no coffee no sugar none of that [__]
um
I did have an espresso today just
because someone made me one and I didn't
want to they didn't know and I was like
I can't let it go to waste
you guys like uh you [__] [__] I
had to admit it to I was gonna sit there
and be like look at me I can just not do
it you know I came downstairs
you know my lovely wife had made it for
me and I came downstairs
because the coffee cup she got me the
espresso cuffs from they could fit two
shots but they're really small but the
the um
the coffee maker that she got me uh you
know the spouts go out both sides and
the cups were too small so I had to put
a bigger cup down there but I wanted the
little mob boss one
so she got me the bigger ones so she was
showing me that I was like you know I
can't drink that she goes oh I just want
to show you that was in the bigger cup
so I was like I gotta go downstairs and
look at it and once I looked at it
smelled I was like all right I have you
gonna drink that and she hates espresso
so
I was like all right well this is just
the one so I'll add another day at some
point
whatever [__] you guys I'm trying okay
[Laughter]
um
I am also uh
I'm gonna get back to doing some
stand-up I haven't done stand up in a
few weeks maybe that's another thing
bumming me out but uh I'm gonna start
doing some stand-up around town I got a
whole bunch of new [__] because I've
been out
um
living a life here and uh having a good
time until this afternoon
um
I'm Gonna Fly tomorrow and tomorrow my
goal is there's a couple of airports
that I'm really intimidated by
uh soloing into so I'm gonna do that
there's a few that I've wanted to go to
for a long time like I want to go to
Santa Barbara
but Santa Barbara is this whole [__]
thing where once you start flying up the
coast you got to get on with the
approach and then there's this whole way
they bring you in
and they get really you know they get
really like uh prickly if you don't know
what you're doing the bottom line is
they just sort of yell at you
right
did I ever tell you guys when I was
first learning how to fly I I learned
how to fly this school doesn't exist
anymore it was down in Long Beach it's a
great airport down there
um and I learned how to fly there so I
was doing my first cross-country solo
and cross country sounds like you're
going all the way across the country
you're not you're only flying like I
think it's like 20 nautical miles and
you have to you but you have to like
either set down off airport or you know
do an approach at an airport for to be
able to log it as cross country
so
I'm [__] doing this thing and uh you
fly out of
Long Beach I remember oh my God I
remember I was
starting the helicopter up it was a
little R22 it was in the summer it was
in June and it was hot as [__] and I
didn't leave the door open and I was all
nervous and [__] and the [__] it just
kept getting hotter and hotter inside
that bubble
and uh of course I make my radio call
and I Did It On The Ground too when I
was still on the ground and you know to
get clearance and the tower told me to
hold so I'm holding and I'm sweating
and there's an instructor with a student
in a helicopter behind me to follow me
to help me out in case I get lost I
think and not only they could do
anything if I had a problem
but I knew that they were sitting there
and then finally I got the clearance and
I just [__] yanked
uh the collective which is the uh the
emergency brick and dude I just shot up
in the air and then I was like I was
bucking a Bronco for a second and I just
had to you know for half a second was
like oh my God what the [__]
it was only for like a split second or
whatever and I just went to myself like
all right
just [__] calm down get your [__]
together so and then
started taking off that air started
coming into the cabin and I was able to
relax
sort of right
so now I'm flying you fly up north
Downey then you might make a right on
still remember this 91 East
so then I got out and then all of a
sudden I was out of
Long Beach Airport and you know I'd done
so many flights there that that's your
little Airy space where you feel okay
and you recognize the people's voices on
the tower all of a sudden and now I'm
just out and
the real [__] here right I'm [__] out
there so I'm going 91 East and there's
this airport Fullerton
I remember I went by there and the call
you was supposed to make is Fullerton
Tower helicopter blah blah blah
uh you know 91 East uh requesting uh
whatever requesting East
91 East uh transition
and I said Fullerton traffic
uh which is basically the call you make
when you're just sort of not in
anybody's airspace as far as an airport
you were just basically in Echo airspace
General airspace so you just say LA
traffic blah blah blah blah and then you
know there's all these reporting points
Capital Records building so people know
where the [__] you are what altitude
you're at and which direction you're
going so that's when you say traffic but
I call the tower you're supposed to say
Fullerton Tower and I said Fullerton
like Fullerton traffic student pilot uh
this guy is [__] [__] he starts
yelling at I literally said student
pilot
you know you know I'm freaking out right
and he goes you don't say he goes this
is a tower you're calling a tower you
say Fullerton Tower and I went fully
traffic and I just was you know I was
like stuck and he just kept yelling at
me and then he finally gave me clearance
and that was like just to begin the
flight I'm like ah [__] right [__] it
up man I'm yanking the collect what the
[__] am I doing I'm talking to myself I
kept looking at that empty goddamn seat
next to me going like man if something
happens I better [__]
I hope I know what I'm doing right
so then you go 91 then it's kind of all
right you just gotta there's some wires
out there you just got to make sure
whatever altitude I figure what altitude
you needed to be at but I made sure I
was above that and if I saw wires I
passed over the tower as opposed to
where the wires are so you can see what
you're flying over right doing all of
that then you go by Corona which is a uh
uncontrolled there's no Tower so
I was thinking okay that's great so
there'll be nobody to yell at me I
didn't realize that those [__] you
know those un uncontrolled ones is where
a bunch of yahoos like me practice
because they don't want to get yelled at
by the guy down at Fullerton
so fortunately there was nobody there
you know zipping around not on the
[__] radio as they seem to love to do
as they seem to love to do right so
um
I basically uh
I [__] uh I don't know so I went by
then I had to go over to Riverside
that's what I had to go over to [__]
Riverside that was a controlled airport
and I went in there Jesus Christ I'm
[__] dropping everything here so I go
in there and uh
I do that one fine and then he got to
take off and try desperately not to get
lost
that was the thing like trying not to
get [__] lost when you come out of
there to go back onto the 91 and not do
whatever that 50 something or 15 North
was I remember that
and um
and then you made like this turn to the
South that I went all the way out to
[__] French Valley
and I think that went all right
I believe that went up wait long story
short I ended up [__] doing the
flight fine
um I think when I left French Valley I I
he wanted me to take off
which whatever I did I kind of did wrong
and this guy had to do a [__] go
around
playing I believe
yeah it's a rough one okay
so then I [__] um
I ended up uh I get back
and unless you have three hours on the
Hobbs meter which is basically the
odometer like but for a helicopter or a
plane you had to log three hours time
and if you came back before that you'd
you know you'd have to do it again which
means not only do you have to do it
again you also have to pay to do it
again all the fuel and all of that [__]
so they say look if you come back if you
fly too fast and you come back
just fly the pattern you know so that's
what I ended up doing I came back and I
was about 15 minutes early so I can't
you know I went by Fullerton again and I
went forward in traffic well guys like
it's the same guy it's full at the tower
fall into Tower you say fall into town
like student pilot falling in traffic
holy [__] so he [__]
I get through his airspace and then I go
to go down you know over to Long Beach
North Downey approach I asked for a pad
assignment made the left turn into the
downwind and then I [__] landed
you know on one of the pads there and
then they used to have four pads I think
they're down to three
and uh and I just flew the pattern for
like 15 minutes and I just kept looking
I think it was like down between your
legs is where the pops was on the
Robinson I can't remember I just kept
looking down going [__] I gotta do it
again I'd fly around
and then finally it flipped over it was
three hours and I went you know
you know left traffic over there with LA
helicopters or Atlantic whatever the
[__] the call was
and I came around I remember when I set
that [__] thing I'll never forget
when I when I pulled the mixture and the
engine shut off
the [__] relief
of like oh my God thank God I did it
right
you know I shut it down everything I put
the wheels on it I dragged it back into
the parking spot next to all the other
22s
and uh
I logged it whatever talked to my
instructor blah blah blah blah and I
just remembered
like for the next like three hours
like I was in I don't I don't know what
headspace I had to go into to be able to
do that but I was sort of locked in it
and people were talking to me and I
wasn't really listening to that and the
only other time I've ever felt like that
was after I did that show in Philly when
I got booed by all of those people
I just remember for like the next day
just walking around New York and
everybody I saw I was trying to like
think of an insult for him
oh I had that feeling another time too I
was playing uh
what is that what's the highest
um award you can win as a soldier Medal
of Honor I was playing Medal of Honor
and I played it all day one day and then
I had to go out and go do my spots and
there was a lot of sniper shooting in
that and when I went out on the street I
was looking across the street at people
and that little X was for me on their
heads
um
anyway
so for the longest time Fullerton bugged
me I I
um
I went into uh I sold in there though
last year and I kind of slayed that one
so then this there's another one that I
um I'm not gonna talk about until I
actually
to like go in there successfully so
anyway
um there you go so there you go okay oh
Billy becomes a sad sack every once in a
while
you know he has tough days and then he
has his little hobbies to try to pull
him out of it
um all right so you know what I actually
saw something on Instagram I know
hilarious right is that true or not they
were talking about for stress if you
breathe in through your nose nice deep
breath of air and before you let it out
you do another quick inhale it inflates
all these other little areas of your
lungs you don't use and then your nice
big exhale you get this all this carbon
dioxide out of you and it allegedly
brings your stress level down now I've
been doing that and it feels like it
works but I can't tell if it's like uh
what is that
[__] uh Vladimir Putin's dog whatever
the
plavsky's dog what's that [__] thing
if you go to a party somebody's gonna
say it one of those ex you know
somebody's gonna say oh it's like uh
Pavlov's dog oh is it is that what it's
like or is it like every [__] party
you go to somebody always has to say
that
do they build no occasionally somebody
says it and I never can [__] remember
it makes me feel stupid so now I'm
lashing out against people I don't even
know what parties I don't go to all
right here's a live reef for this week
movement everybody mvmt
empty
uh you're missing that final piece to
level up your life movement mvmt is your
new favorite watch brand uh their small
team of dreamers in Venice Beach
California have perfect perfected Sleek
original Ultra Clean watch design and
for Valentine's Day oh [__] oh [__] it's
all about her isn't it
uh they're going all in with a huge sale
so you can give the most thoughtful
tried and true lasting gift a movement
mvmt watch hey ladies why don't you do
this for your guy get him a nice stylish
watch for a price that's right why don't
you surprise them and get off your
[__] tush and act like there's two
people in the relationship huh rather
than him having to [__] whine you you
Dinah Dice Clay Shadow uh why mvmt
watches
makes a great gift uh time is a
beautiful and meaningful sentiment
perfect for Valentine's Day they'll see
it and think of you every day also
perfect for Valentine's Day Why move why
a movement
is a great watch fresh modern designs by
a team of weekend Mavericks who know
what it means to go from nine to five
work days to five to nine Good Times
baby and every Adventure in between
comes with a little razor blade
underneath it to cut your Coke up with
or fend off an attacker elegant pre
that doesn't come with that elegant
precise Japanese watch movements and
Industry leading I'll tell you right now
when elegant precise Japanese the second
I heard that my buddy had an 81 Toyota
Tercel and to this [__] day that is
the smoothest shifting car I've ever
driven in my life
all right
so they're making these watches now an
industry leading materials from complex
Ceramics to sophisticated automatics
solar powered dials uh to upcycled Ocean
plastic
cases
upcycled ocean plastic cases oh they're
taking plastic out of the ocean to make
cases wouldn't it be great if they just
did that
you got to show these corporations this
money to be made and then you wear it
and then you throw it out it goes back
in the ocean that'll be the new our new
Farmland uh meanwhile the fish are
breathing it in uh the epitome of bang
for your buck with huge value and style
your wrist and wallet will both love
well maybe in the future they'll be like
well we don't have to go pay to get it
from the ocean just bring it over to us
shut up Bill all right uh you've got the
hook up with our friends at movement
mvmt save on your best Valentine's Day
gift ever with 20 off of mvmt Michael
Victor Michael tango.com and use code
Bill Burr that's mvmt.com codebur for 20
off all right there you go my podcast
studio is fixed it is back
um I am psyched about that I am thankful
for that and um
I'm talking to my my Booker gonna get
some stand updates on the books I'm
ready to go out because I don't want to
spend my days 1 30 in the afternoon of
my slippers being Billy Sad Sack here
all right enjoy the music picked out by
the wonderful extremely talented
um Andrew femalis and then we'll have a
bonus episode of the Monday Morning
podcast uh no the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast that is all enjoy the Pro Bowl
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday February 2nd 2015. how you doing
how the [__] ah yeah
um I know what you guys are all
expecting
you guys are all expecting me for to get
on this [__] podcast and to start
going absolutely [__] crazy because
the New England Patriots won another
[__] Super Bowl and beat the
loudmouth green [__] from Seattle you
know what there is nothing that I would
love to do more than that
I would love to sit here and tell you
that I enjoyed every [__] second of
that goddamn game
but unfortunately old freckles missed
the game
every [__] second of that game I
missed and I know what you guys are
thinking what Jesus Built were you
kidnapped did somebody chloroform rag
you what the [__] happened
um what happened was is I booked this
[__] tour in Australia New Zealand
it's Singapore
I hope this is record he's not gonna be
too loud I'm doing it on my [__]
iPhone because uh you know because I'm
in [__] New Zealand and I can't get
any Outlets to work and my batteries
don't [__] work I'm just having a
technological nightmare here anyways you
know I booked this [__] tour
back in November
how the hell did I know the Patriots
were going to be in the goddamn Super
Bowl I didn't know you know I'm one of
the few [__] football fans that
actually admits that he had no [__]
idea what his team was going to do this
year I had no idea
you know
um I can't [__] believe anyone I just
landed I was literally in the air the
exact moment the [__] game started
and when I landed it was [__] over I
missed absolutely everything uh I'm
obviously unbelievably psyched that we
won
for a number of [__] reasons
aside from the obvious you know
more so than [__] excited that we won
I'm just so happy that I didn't get half
to watch
Richard Sherman run into [__] Brady's
face and disrespect the guy again that
whole [__] you mad bro thing I just I
don't know you know you're running up to
a champion the guy's got three rings you
won a regular season game and you treat
him like he's a [__] rookie I mean I
don't know I've never liked people that
do that type of [__] I'm sure he's a
hell of a guy to sit down and have a
[__] cappuccino with but I just you
know all that mugging to the camera and
[__] I've already seen the highlights
where he did the 24th thing and all that
and I'm sure that's another thing that
would have kind of ruined the Super Bowl
for me was every five seconds they got
to cut over to him or his reaction I
hate when they do that to Tom Brady like
if the other team scores and you got to
see Tom Brady sitting there with that
I'm mad look on his face it's like I
this there's too much [__] coverage
at this point haven't said all of that
um I'm so it's this is this is the weird
kind of like [__] excitement
like the level of excitement I have
right now is I I guess I know what it
feels like before the days of TV and
radio you know we just live in the
middle of nowhere and someone walks up
to you and like Ethel did you hear we
won the war
really
that's what I feel like right now I got
on a [__] [__] plane
and um
yeah I missed the whole thing and I was
praying to God that they were going to
have live TV because they had sports
bars down here that had the [__] game
on and everything and
um you know I know what a lot of you
guys are going to see well why didn't
you change your [__] flight
because I am on the other side of the
[__] world and I can't miss shows
because of a [__] football game be it
the Super Bowl I'll not be the Super
Bowl okay with Tom Brady [__] cancel
a flight to watch one of my specials I
don't think he would you know I don't
want to get all Bronx tail on you right
now but I you know I got a [__] life
I gotta lead here so
um
oh my God I can't believe I missed the
[__] game but uh pardon me when I saw
the ending and there was another [__]
ridiculous catching the ball against
your helmet and your ball bag catch and
it looked like we were going to lose
again I literally would have died a
thousand deaths I can tell you right now
I would have missed that interception
because after that [__] catch I would
have been walking outside doing laps
around my house like you got to be
[__] kidding me
um
but anyways uh I'm psyched that we won
obviously
and um you know my condolences to
Seattle Seahawk fans the real ones the
ones from back in the Kingdome era the
ones that are still going to be in your
[__] Stadium after Pete Carroll's
gone and everybody's [__] gone and
you guys you know stink again the same
way the Patriots will stink again when
Belichick and Brady leave those the real
[__] fans I feel bad for you all you
[__] loudmouth [__] talking [__]
[__] who wear those lime green wigs you
were the guys that I'm happy that you
[__] suffered that loss go [__]
yourselves with your stupid 12th man
[__] shirts
do you know I heard Seattle actually has
to pay
the college Texas A M for that 12th man
thing that they didn't come up with that
you know so they got to pay them and not
to mention the Buffalo Bills had a
12-man thing you know back in the early
[__] 90s
I don't know I'm just so [__] happy
that we won and that uh you know who
knows I'm sure they'll [__] they'll
measure the thread count
in the [__] towels that we were using
to dry the balls off with I'm sure Jim
irsay is somewhere trying to figure out
a [__] way to try to taint this
[__] Victory I swear to Christ did
you guys see that thing where the
Atlanta Falcons maybe got busted for for
pumping extra crowd noise in did you
happen to catch that story I swear to
God if the Patriots did something like
that we would literally be sitting down
in front of the [__] Senate
you know that was another thing another
reason why I was so [__] happy that
we won because I'm so [__] sick of
winning games and these [__] [__]
bitching about
absolute horseshit
at the end of the [__] game I mean
deflategate deflategate all of that
[__] [__] and and nobody brings up
how many people on the [__] Seattle
Seahawks team have tested positive for
steroids over the last four [__]
years
nobody brings up that Pete Carroll had a
championship taken away from him for
[__] cheating and I gotta tell you
something I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] that Seattle used
steroids I'm sure we're [__] using
them too and whatever [__] Pete
Carroll did at the college level I know
there's a bunch of other coaches doing
the same [__] thing so I don't know
why people get [__] with us but who
gives a [__] we won the goddamn thing
and I am literally sitting out here
in the [__] Abyss that's like I'm
ridiculously excited
like this must be like what it's like to
find out the Patriots one if you're
sitting in [__] Walpole prison
and like solitary confinement I can't
[__] believe I missed it
Jesus [__] Christ I'm sitting there
watching documentaries about cricket
[Laughter]
my [__] headphones won't work down
here nothing's [__] working
um so anyways if you call if you [__]
are listening this week to hear my blow
by blow horseshit you're not gonna get
it this week so I suggest you listen to
another podcast but if you want to know
what my [__] Australian tour is like
in into New Zealand that's basically uh
I guess what I'm going to be I can't
[__] believe what are the [__]
odds
what are the [__] odds that literally
from the time my flight started to when
it ended that was the exact time that
the game was on
um I I don't know anything about the
game I really don't I just know in the
end is that Seattle was up by 10 points
and for some reason they're going to say
that they lost the game by not running
Marshawn Lynch in but I would just say
that if you were up 10 points
with a quarter to go there's more than
one reason why you lost that [__]
game and uh you know I don't think it's
the worst call in Super Bowl history I
think it's going to be called that
because it didn't work
you know what I mean and uh
if it [__] works then he's a genius I
mean talk about guts everybody in the
building is keying on Marshawn Lynch and
he dumps you know that that was going to
be the [__] thing I'm just so happy
that the Patriots didn't lose another
Super Bowl on some [__] Circus catch
I swear to God after the helmet catch
well I guess you know I didn't actually
mind the [__] helmet catch as much as
I met I I was annoyed that Asante Samuel
dropped that interception other than
that the 2007 Super Bowl wasn't that bad
because I felt that the Giants were a
better team the second giant loss that
one was brutal because we [__] blew
that game
um we [__] blew that game we had the
right call and it was Brady to Welker
eight yard pass wide open and it bounces
off his back [__] shoulder that would
have ice the game that was a [__]
brutal one but uh that first one uh we
definitely lost so anyways there you go
now the championship for Boston how do
you like that New York City huh nine
championships
in like 12 Seasons what do you got 58
[__] teams and you can't even do that
yeah it's [__] unreal
um
oh Jesus Christ why am I [__] on
[__] New York you know I'm [__]
on New York because my [__] team won
the Super Bowl and I didn't even get to
[__] see it unbelievable unfucking
believable so I guess I taped the game
so I'm gonna have to watch it
after I do gigs in New Zealand and then
Singapore
Hong Kong Mumbai India and then I go to
New York for the Patrice O'Neill uh
benefit speaking of which last night but
when it let me let me just finish here
seriously dude my condolences to to uh
the Seattle Seahawks fans I know I'm
breaking your balls a little bit there's
nothing [__] worse than losing a
goddamn Super Bowl and to lose it like
that in the [__] end I know it
[__] blows
um
but you know
he just got [__] with all that ex
extra [__] horseshit hype about you
guys being loud you know it got a little
annoying
so maybe I am being a little bit of a
[__] what are you gonna do anyways
um
plowing ahead here
uh
speaking of the Patrice O'Neal uh comedy
benefit that we're doing for the third
time
um which I want to thank everybody over
the last three years who've bought
tickets because you've really you've
changed people's lives that Patrice
loved all right I'm not going to get
into the details of it but like you know
this this Charity's on the up and up all
right just know that
you know we're not doing a show with a
pink microphone
[Laughter]
um this is so [__] up people tweeted
me so much [__]
about awful commercials during the Super
Bowl and I just had no I literally you
know I might as well have been orbiting
the Earth in the [__] space shuttle
that's like how how much how little I
know about whatever the [__] happened
um I do know that it looked like a hell
of a game and uh
you know my heart said we were going to
win I had a feeling we were going to win
but my brain said that uh
you know on paper we were going to lose
and to be honest with you before the
game started when I was thinking about
it I had no feeling one way or the other
uh I didn't have a bad feeling like we
were going to win I didn't have a good
feeling
if we won by 40 or lost by 40 I would I
I don't think either would have
surprised me I just had no [__] ID on
this one so
um anyways I feel like I'll let you guys
down because I was you know I'm doing
this [__]
goddamn tour and you wanted to hear me
gloat and [__] but uh you know I'm not a
guy I'm not a guy who [__] gloats
anyways come on I break balls but I
don't [__] dude I'm not gonna [__]
sit here and go act like I played the
goddamn game but um
anyways and as much as I don't like the
way Richard Sherman acts when he [__]
wins that guy is one of the best corners
in the [__] Lake he is and I wish he
was on my team although I wouldn't like
to watch that [__] dumb [__] that he
does
um so anyways uh like I said speaking of
the Patrice O'Neill benefit
um
last night I was playing the uh the
Sydney Opera House which is was a
ridiculous honor playing two shows there
and at the end of the show somebody in
the front row handed me a shirt that
they made
um that had Patrice I'll take a picture
of it it's [__] unreal it has Patrice
on the front and then on the back is
Patrice talking to me and it's got Colin
Quinn
uh Keith Robinson Jim Norton
uh who love Robert Kelly's in it it's
the [__] shirt is unbelievable and uh
the person that formal just handed it to
me as I was getting off this you know as
I was getting off really quick so I just
grabbed it and I just you know I handed
him my set list from the show which I
hope didn't come off as a douchey move I
just
kind of getting off stage there and um I
didn't have a chance to look at at it
until I got backstage
um whoever you are that made that shirt
please try and reach out to me on
Twitter or whatever because uh
you know I wish I could have thanked you
um personally for because it's a [__]
unbelievable
uh piece of work I don't know how the
hell you did it and I wish you made more
of them
um
because I know all my friends would love
one it was just amazing but um anyways
I'm about a week into this tour
of uh Australia and it has been uh
you know I'm just thinking right now I'm
thinking of all the Patriots fans that
are just [__] shutting it off right
now going what the [__] dude I thought
he was gonna go off I'm sorry I didn't
see the game
ah
goodness
anyways let me get back into the you
know what I did do this week I I saw
some tennis
does that help you out at all this
sports fans
I um
I I went to the Australian Open
I saw some tennis
I saw Maria Sharapova in the semis and I
saw uh Serena Williams both win in the
semis to play each other in the finals
and uh if you've never been to a tennis
match this is so [__] funny to be
doing this the day after a Super Bowl I
might as well be baking a pie right now
um
if you've never been to a
to a [__] tennis match you know just
the level of wealth
that is there like you know um you know
what first of all the tickets weren't
that hard to get
like uh you know I just scalped a pair
of them you know I'm not gonna lie you
know they were like 300 bucks a whack
but I'm like [__] it man
you know it's it's
one of the Mages I'll [__] you know
bring it up on the card I'll deal with
it later right [__] it and when you go
there
like the level of [__] wealth that's
sitting around there and they smell it
on you when you show up the second they
see the fact that you're not wearing
loafers with no socks on they just look
at you like you're a [__] animal you
know you watch them getting all boozed
up and [__] and I always get excited
when I sit around those people just I
just want to ask them you know [__] like
you know
when's the dollar gonna collapse like
what's the inside information that you
[__] know you know those people that
like they sit there right
they have tickets for the whole day we
just had for the afternoon right and
they're sitting there and they got they
wear like the sweaters you know where
you you're not wearing it you just have
it draped over your shoulder you don't
you don't have it tied around your neck
you just have it draped over I think
that's the new way to do it and they're
not doing it like ironically
like they they have a sweater for when
it gets cold later when they're watching
the tennis
but anyways we sat close enough
um
and got got to watch Serena right before
she won the uh the 19th her 19th
Championship so I got to do that I went
to bond Scott's grave
when I was out in uh when I was out in
Perth
and um it was really cool they had a
little bench there because I guess
Bond's mother for as far as I know is
still alive she's well into her 90s and
up until recently would go down and
visit the grave every almost every day
which of course is really sad but they
so they made they raised some money they
made like a little bench for her and
everything and uh
out it's it's if you ever get a chance
to go to Australia man perfect first of
all Perth is the [__] I talked to some
woman when I was here in the states and
she tried to tell me you know she was
from Australia she was [__] all over
it saying like it was
you know that it was [__] horrific or
whatever it's uh it's quite the opposite
man very impressive City seems like the
kind of place where you'd uh
vacation or something man beautiful
beaches that was nothing Cool Tools we
uh we went down to the beach one day
and I quit laughing [__] you I know I'm
pasty but I had to do it you know
um
and
just to see the Indian Ocean
you know never seen that and uh my wife
of course went in the ocean because she
[__] loves the ocean and I sort of
frolicked along the [__] along the
[__] beach I just do not go I went
into the water just to say I've been in
the [__] Indian Ocean but I do not
[__] with
I just don't [__] with the ocean on any
level and um
but if I was gonna [__] with it I would
go all in like I would get certified to
scuba dive and the next time I come here
I would go to the Great Barrier Reef and
I would do that before I would [__]
just start
I don't know swimming along the [__]
Coast you know like I guess that the
Sharks come out
in the morning they're basically out
when the seals are out so you don't want
to be out when the seals are out I guess
it's early morning and dusk or something
and
um
they were telling me some [__] story
where there was a helicopter following
an 18-foot tiger shark just keeping an
eye on it to make sure it didn't go into
the beach area I mean give me a [__]
break I'm not going to that goddamn
water
you know what's funny about the
Australians down here too when they talk
about somebody getting attacked by a
shark they don't say you got attacked
they say you got taken
and I was like yeah there was a bloke
got taken I don't say bloke I came what
the [__] they said this would be like
some dude got taken
about 20 miles up they told the story I
don't even know if this is true if
they're just trying to scare a tourist
but they were saying this [__] guy
was surfing
and he was you know
not waiting for a wave he was in the
wave riding the wave I should say in the
[__] shark jumped out of the water
and grab them like some Sharknado [__]
like I mean it jumped out of the [__]
wall I thought you had to have like your
arms hanging off the board and then from
underneath you look like a seal
sort of a strange shaped seal or
whatever but if you're if you're [__]
on the board at that point if they're
jumping out of the water I don't know
I don't know look I'm saying I don't
[__] with the water but I had a uh
I really had a great time in Perth uh my
favorite beer out here is that little
creatures
and uh turns out they had a brewery and
I was able to go to the brewery I could
have taken the tour but I don't
understand going
taking a tour of a [__] Brewery
looking at the uh The Distillery process
all I look at is like the entire time
I'm taking this tour I could be drinking
your product fresh out of your [__]
big silver whatever the [__] you call
those things
so uh boost it up there
um went over to bond Scott's grave like
I mentioned and uh you know it's funny
when you get there like people leave all
it's kind of weird people leave like all
these
you know bottles of booze there it's
like the guy kind of died from that you
know I mean somebody overdoses on heroin
do you leave like [__] used needles
there it's really weird
I kind of felt bad when I showed up
someone there was an empty Miller
Genuine Draft bottle
next to bond Scott's grave and the uh
the ACD not only the AC DC fan in me the
beer lover and me wanted to take it away
from the grape but there was just
something about removing something from
that place just seeing the little uh
sacrilegious so I I refrained from doing
that but if you ever get to Perth they
have this own little entrance
a little Gateway and you come walk it
says Bond Scott entry or something like
that I took I'll have all the pictures
up on the podcast I I did uh retweet
some of this [__] but you walk in
um very easy headstone to find and uh if
you look down on the ground they have
like a lightning bolt like the AC DC
lightning bolt in the pay meant and then
above it is like a looks like a record
and then they had something else I
forget what it was
um which is really cool so it just sort
of guides you right to it and um
and then if you go over down onto the
wall the water where they have the
little creatures
makes their beer and [__] a little bit
further up from that they have a statue
of Bon Scott which I think used to be in
the graveyard but they moved it because
I guess back in the day he was a
deckhand or a decki as they call it down
here in Australia so they uh they put
them down there on the water and um
I don't know it was really cool and uh
where did I go from there then I went to
Melbourne
I got there and that was a uh that's
when I saw the Australian Open did a
couple shows that night
and
um evidently some Comics came out to see
me throughout this tour I'm glad I
didn't know they were in the crowd that
would have made me [__] nervous
um
and I've basically been putting together
my new hour out here watching this thing
come together getting my [__]
stand-up shops back together again it's
gonna [__] just been a great tour I
really want to thank everybody who came
out in um
you know throughout my time here in
Australia this has been [__]
incredible to come out here and play
these big venues and be adding shows and
stuff uh oh then I did Brisbane
and um
had a [__] uh
I don't know I had one of my best shows
I had in Brisbane and in I I got all I
got pictures of all this [__] sorry guys
I'm a little [__] jet lagged I know
this [__] isn't funny I'm just kind of
going through my [__] tour here I
played City Hall there it's one of the
best looking theaters I ever played
literally you could shoot a [__]
special there it was phenomenal
um oh here's I got a funny [__] story
for you all right listen to this [__] so
I'm going through [__] security
all right
and they have the regular metal detector
and then they got the [__] x-ray one
that I don't go through
I don't go through that [__] thing
because I don't give a [__] what they
tell me that thing is not good for you I
remember when it first [__] came out
and people were opting out and I
remember people going like oh it's a big
deal you're already talking on your cell
phone like all that dumb [__] that
people say you know
um
yeah it's like oh yeah so why don't I
get extra radiation you know but I just
add to it just make sure I get [__]
cancer right and what do they say they
try to say that the thing was totally
[__] safe and then what ends up
happening after a year and a half of
radiating everybody in my country too
much they realized that they had the
[__] thing turned up too high and to
this [__] day when you go through one
of those if a kid's young enough they
they [__] send them around
because it [__] retards the puberty
process or something like that but I'm
supposed to go through it go [__]
yourself so I always opt out and I don't
give a [__] about your opinion on this
by the way I don't need to hear your
[__] opinion this is just my opinion
if you want to go through the [__]
thing more power to you so I'm down here
in Australia and they got the regular
one and then they got the [__] the
bad one
so every third person or whatever it has
to go through or whatever so I come up
and guess what they want me to go
through that other one and I'm like yeah
I'm opting out and they like you can't
opt out
Australia so now I'm in this [__]
thing where I'm challenging Authority in
a different country which is always
scary
but I just said I'm not I'm not
I'm not going through it
when the guy starts going like oh
he goes do you mind if I ask you why and
I go yeah because I used to work in a
dental office and I took [__] X-rays
and I put a lead vest over somebody
before I [__] took an x-ray and I got
cancer in my family so I don't want to
go through it and he goes well you can't
opt out here plus the ones down here he
goes this thing is he goes this thing
only sees through your pockets this
[__] rent-a-clop like he knows how
this [__] thing works right
oh it just sees through your pockets
really you fat [__] what do you know
about anything other than eating too
many [__] Donuts you douche right so
I say to the guy
I go well we had the one in the states
they had it turned up too high goes this
is a different one I go no it isn't
I go that's the same company I'm not
going through it
he goes all right well then you have to
stand over there I'm like fine so the
guy [__] makes me stand over there
for like 10 minutes then this other
[__] guy comes walking over and he's
got this little [__]
do you know like when the you know like
when you get your baseball team schedule
or your hockey team schedule for the
[__] year he comes over with one with
one of those
that's like four pages most of it is
pictures
and he goes if you just want to read up
on it and I've just started laughing
like what that little kids book you have
there that explains that complex [__]
machine over there
and he goes no it explains it I go who
explained it the people who made that
[__] thing I'm obviously not cursing
at him
but they just said you can't [__] opt
out it's a law down here now if I had
the [__] time and the where with all
the presence of mine during that
conversation I should have said tell me
what law it is
tell me what [__] law that says I
have to go through that [__] thing
Pat me down we don't do that here well
you should [__] start
[__] unreal so then I ended up having
to go through the goddamn thing
the guy was actually nice he apologized
for it I just said listen man I know
it's not you it's this is what it always
is it's not you you're just the guy here
who has to tell me I have to [__] go
through it but the real [__] who are
making money off it who fly [__]
private who never have to go through
that thing don't have to worry about
having their entire [__] head all the
way down they have balls in their
[__] toes radiated
so is if there's anybody out there that
has a [__] scientific background and
can explain to me how something that can
seep through my [__] clothes it's not
it's not a uh
it's not some sort of an x-ray
I mean Jesus Christ drinking Coca-Cola
can give you cancer you're telling me
standing in that [__] thing
head to [__] toe put your arms up oh
it just shoots beams at you it's just
looking at what's in your pockets oh
yeah is that why when I come out the
other side there's an entire image of me
I don't know so whatever so that was my
[__] big goddamn moment
[__] fat [__] make making me stand
there for Life another thing that they
do that passive aggressive thing is they
make you stand there for [__] 10
minutes
trying to break your will
knowing that you're probably late for
your flight
I [__] hate myself that I didn't say
you know what let me uh
let me see the [__] uh why don't you
show me the goddamn [__]
law that I don't know I'm sorry I'm
looking at all these people's tweets now
saying uh
hey bro hope tour is going great this is
from like my friends here
hearing good things about your movie
Black or White some of my friends
saw it so did Mom and Dad they liked it
uh nice nice
very nice hey by the way can you guys
please go go check out black black or
white if you got a chance this week uh
you know it's a really big deal for me
um if you go and see it I made a lot of
friends in that movie and uh Kevin
Costner uh kind of put up his money for
the whole [__] movie he financed the
thing so uh not saying you have to go
see it I would really appreciate it if
you did all right it's getting great
reviews by the way
all right now write all your negative
[__] you're gonna say about I don't give
a [__] all right live reads here we go
Sherry's Berries everybody I'm reading
reading in New Zealand
she does not want anything for
Valentine's Day what she means is is get
me something for Valentine's Day don't
you love how this [__] holiday is
just so geared toward broads
I just don't understand this whole
[__] holiday and like how it's just
about them what about that when they
express their love to us isn't that
there's some somewhere there's that
[__] day and they completely blow it
off because we don't give a [__] the
last thing we want them to do is to talk
more to us even if they're saying
something nice anyways
I actually love this advertising and I I
totally endorse this this is exactly
what you should get throwing a stuffed
bear too there you go sweetheart and if
she gives you [__] all you got to say is
the [__] did you get me
you know exactly
each of strawberry smell your flowers
and shut your face and tonight you're
cuddling with the bear because I'm sick
of you
um get it done early before it's too
late profiles makes it easy to check off
the list even if you already have
Valentine's Day plans you still need
flowers delivered it's a must when she
says she does when she says she doesn't
need flowers she means you better get me
flowers boy isn't that convenient is
that what she means people who sell
flowers
how come it doesn't mean I want to
[__] butter basted uh pork chop
all right go to floaproflowers.com click
on the blue microphone in the top right
hand corner and type in Burr b-u-r-r
that's proflowers.com click on the
microphone and type in burnt Burr order
today this deal expires Friday at
midnight
all right
I'm sure I'll get some [__] about those
but they don't understand that I know
who you guys are and that that'll make
you actually buy those [__] things
you know Valentine's Day what are you
gonna get her
what's going to happen it's the
stupidest [__] thing ever my wife is
cool as [__] you know what we do I've
told you this for years we don't go out
on Valentine's Day and we don't buy each
other anything we go out like three days
after a couple days before when food
costs what it's supposed to cost we sit
down we have a nice meal we shoot this
[__] and that's that's [__] it
I don't go to CVS and buy [__]
all that [__] confetti whatever the
[__] it is you're supposed to do I don't
know I'm in such a [__] mood because I
missed the Super Bowl I can't [__]
believe it and we want God damn it we
want I'm so [__] psyched we want on
not even winning I'm just so psyched I
don't have to hear it from Seattle fans
I'm so psyched I don't have to listen to
another [__] goddamn story about how
[__] loud they are and that and
nobody addressing that the stadium is
built to make them louder than they
really are uh
[__] drives me up the wall but
whatever you know what this is the first
24 hours I'm sure Jim irsay will figure
out a way to say somehow we were
cheating all right
let's get into the questions for this
week everybody
um
wait have I told all my [__] stories
I really don't have a lot of stories
about here being down here in Australia
other than the people are unbelievably
friendly it's really relaxed it's an a
ridiculously underrated place to go
and
um for tennis fans if you want to go to
a great City
and if you want to go to an unbelievable
[__] venue go go to the Australian
Open
and go into the rod Leyva [__] Arena
I mean
I went to the U.S open like twice like
10 12 years ago and it's a giant for
tennis it's still a huge it's a really
big venue and you know we were sitting
up top and they would you know
they were very far away this this venue
I swear to God it felt like I was
watching it with 600 other people
like you could hear everything like
Serena would throw the ball up
and if you know like when you throw it
up and then you don't serve you know you
just felt weird you just grabbed the
ball to serve again he'd literally hear
her go sorry sorry
I felt like I was at our house
and she was playing in the backyard or
something it was amazing and um
I would say that Melbourne is probably
the uh
like if you're I don't know I would say
that that's sort of the New York City
of uh of Australia I'm gonna get [__]
right now if I'm starting to try to
compare so this is this is me knowing
very little about their country that
seems like more like
you know
I don't know we're all like a lot of the
just where all the [__] is you know you
know how spoiled New Yorkers are since
they grew up in New York everything is
right there so when they go every place
they think every place else sucks I've
kind of noticed that Melbourne people
kind of think every place else sucks
um
but uh
and I think Sydney is more like a
touristy Place both have their Merit or
whatever it all depends on what age you
are which whatever the [__] you're into
and um Brisbane was the [__] I had a
great time up there
beautiful beaches
what do they got the Gold Coast or some
[__] like that around there I don't know
much about it but it was just a
phenomenal place to visit and I was
actually uh I was a little Melancholy
when I was leaving and also
one of the great things is one of one
comedian I actually started out with
Adele Benny I got to uh he married an
Australian girl and uh they relocated
to Sydney outside of Sydney about a year
ago and he hit me up out of the blue
asked if he could come down and uh
hang out for the show and he actually I
threw him on and did about five seven
minutes before each show
and uh
it was great just hanging out with him
talking about the [__] old days
trying to figure out how the hell we
became the old guys like I saw a thing
the other day you know saying like top
20 Comics new Comics to watch so you
know I'm a fan of stand up I want to see
who's coming up and I probably knew like
two of them
and um and I was looking at him going
like Jesus Christ I've been doing
stand-up since all of these
people that they're shown were probably
like anywhere from two years old to
eight years old
so starting to feel my [__] age here
um
but anyways I'm in New Zealand and I
missed the Super Bowl you know if you're
gonna miss a [__] Super Bowl fly to
New Zealand I gotta think is a pretty
good
God I think it's a pretty good excuse
um gotta admit being down here not
hearing any of the Super Bowl hype or
any of that type of [__] I really
[__] enjoyed it did not miss any of
that any of this [__] oh did you hear so
and so said this somebody said this
blah blah blah blah and that [__]
crap
um
so [__] psyched I missed that I'm not
psyched I missed the goddamn game though
um anyways Australian food you know
what's weird I'll actually do a recap of
the Super Bowl when I get back after
like February you know when I'm back
February whatever the [__] I get back at
um I'll watch the game and I'll do a
special I'll do a special podcast
midweek how about that and I'll react to
the game like it just happened
ah Jesus Bill anyways Australian food
let's get to the uh the questions here
for this week
um
hey Bill I'd never been to Australia
I've watched my fair share of Food
Network but I've never heard of
authentic Australian Cuisine the whole
shrimp on the barbie thing has to be
exaggerated and I'm pretty sure the only
people who drink Fosters are morons not
living on that prison Island what's the
meal you've had so far uh what's the
best meal we've had so far and can you
give me some insight as to what you
think
uh as to what they're known for Down
Under down under thanks and go [__]
yourself dude I have to be honest with
you I am barnstorming across this part
of the world
I land I do a show and then I go to the
airport
um occasionally like today I landed in
New Zealand and I have tonight to go out
and grab a quick drink and then tomorrow
um I have to do the show
um I've been doing a lot of press when
I've been over here I haven't really
seen or done [__]
um
I've drank a lot
what are they known for
I don't know the food over here is great
the seafood's obviously tremendous you
know what they're really known for over
here I think they're known for their
beaches
um beautiful people man women over here
[__] uh over and I should not over
here anymore I'm in New Zealand but
they're [__] gorgeous but as far as
the food was the best thing I've had
I gotta tell you something man
I've had some french fries and chips
down here ordered room service this one
[__] hotel is one of the best order
of french fries I've ever [__] had
that's the only thing that I can think
of that's that has stood out other than
that everything the food has been great
um but I mean I haven't had any [__]
kangaroo or any [__] like that I don't
know I have no idea sorry man
um can you guys tell a [__] jet
lagged I am I really apologize for this
[__]
podcast so far
um
El Camino looking cars in Perth okay hey
Bill on last week's podcast you said you
saw two guys in El Camino looking cars
driving like [__] in Perth
um I didn't say [__] I said driving
like people who have El Caminos in
Australia we have cars that we call Utes
and they are similar to the American
pickup but more like a normal sedan
basically they are mostly a unibody like
car rather than a body on frame like a
pickup do you know somebody tried to
tell me that the pickup was invented by
a woman here in uh well over in
Australia
that they used to have what what they
used to have like these Vans sort of
looking
what the hell they used to call those
things
oh God my brain is mushed this week
um what were those [__] things called
begins with a p those vans for like the
1950s but they had they had pickups in
the 1930s I don't know whatever they had
more like a van type thing and this
woman got sick of [__] backing or
something and having to like open the
doors and throw hay in the back and she
just cut the top off of it and somebody
I guess
from the States was over here and saw it
it doesn't sound right
doesn't sound right to me it doesn't
make any [__] sense but somebody
tried to claim that they came up with
them over there anyways our division of
General Motors is called Holden
Commodore which is the current Camaro uh
which the current Camaro is based on and
you can get in the U.S as a Chevy SS
wait a minute I Camaro is based on yours
or your shit's based on our [__]
okay don't get it twisted buddy we came
up with the [__] car we invented the
goddamn car all right didn't we I have
no idea who invented the [__] car we
flew first didn't we
other than those French guys who said
they flew first
how the [__] would we know what you were
doing back then we'd have to take a
[__] ship
um well actually the Camaro was the 60s
I don't know I actually took a picture
of a couple of uh some muscle cars over
here man it's cool because they almost
look like ours but they're not but they
still look badass and actually found a
sleeper this [__] uh mustard colored
wagon man the thing was badass uh I'll
also try and post that that photo let me
finish reading this thing also Ford
Australia builds the falcon
parentheses the Interceptor from Mad Max
was an XB Falcon which can also be
bought as a u
we have both these cars in Australia for
well over 30 years but unfortunately
they will no longer be built here
anymore after 2017. also douchebags love
clapped out Commodores to Hoon about in
case they are cheap and pretty quick
there's some Aussie slang for you I have
no idea what the [__] he's talking about
bragging about Commodores
uh I know you're a Ford guy so you
should really check out some of the
Aussie build Falcons throughout the
years yeah I actually did that I looked
up and uh
check them out I was surprised how much
longer you guys built the falcon
I actually saw a late model falcon that
looked like a [__] Ford Taurus
station wagon when I was outside that
little creatures beer place
um he goes on to say and also if you
have some spare time you should check
out the V8 Supercars it's like
Australian uh NASCAR but they race on a
road course you you know what's funny I
actually mentioned the Corvette one
night when I was on stage out here that
I I love the Corvette and I was thinking
about getting one and people had no idea
what a Corvette was at least the new one
you know they know what I guess some of
the old ones are and I started
sort of looking for Corvettes when I was
in Australia not a one not a one so you
know what if I live down under you know
what I would get I'd get that new
Corvette Z06 have it [__] shipped
over here you'd be the only one on your
block
right and I go [__] drive around
scare some [__] kangaroos
all right Australian woman bill I have a
couple friends who studied abroad in
Australia they they all say that women
down down there are unreal what are your
thoughts to make it fair because you're
with the loving ear uh you or she can
comment about the men as wealth
[__] hilarious uh no good looking
people tall
blonde
um it's weird their eyes though their
eyes they have Aussie eyes it's weird
it's somewhere between white guy eyes
and Asian eyes you know like John Denver
that's what I would say oh [__] that's
what they got they got John Denver eyes
with blonde hair
uh tan people uh really good looking
[__] you know
tall blonde and tan there you go I mean
I don't know what Hitler's feelings were
about Australia but I think he would
have loved it you know if he if he just
he's such a [__] [__] that Hitler
you know why didn't he just [__] take
his easel travel abroad he would have
been interesting he would have had a
[__]
he would have had an accent he could
have come down here got himself some
tall drink of [__] water painted the
beautiful beaches
could have lived out a nice quiet
[__] life right but now he had to go
for the glory
he wanted to get into Showbiz didn't he
uh response to army guy from last week
considering marrying girlfriend to get
her out of the UK
all right this is okay this is this guy
last week who was talking about uh
you know he was he was joined the
[__] some branch of the U.S armed
services and he was stationed over in
England
and the only way he could get his
beautiful perfect girlfriend over to
meet him is uh to live over there was if
he [__] married her so this is what
this guy this is the guy's response here
hey burnout
uh on the 126 podcast there was a guy he
called me oh burn b-u-r-r and I think he
was talking about the guy who's gonna
get married all right hey burn out on
the January 26 podcast there was a guy
who was worried about getting married in
order to get his girlfriend to come to
Europe with him my advice get legally
married but don't have the ceremony
if you just need some documentation to
show you are married this is a great way
to avoid the added stress if you explain
that you love her and you want her to be
with you but you're not ready for
marriage she will likely understand
explain that you still have a regular
wedding later if you decide to make the
emotional commitment also the issue of
getting a prenup can be brought up to
make you feel more secure without her
thinking it's a trust issue
wait him what are you saying
get legally married but don't have the
ceremony so you're already married then
if you're legally married does he need
to get the [__] prenup
I'll continue reading here I was in the
reverse situation when I want when I
wanted to get married to my girlfriend
she had student loans that would get
much more expensive if she was married
so we had the ceremony without the legal
contract we were contact connected
without the added cost
um later when she needed health
insurance we went to the JP and got her
on the insurance just separate the legal
marriage from the emotional one until
you're ready uh for the commitments they
entail thanks to go [__] yourself yeah
but then if you're not
emotionally ready to get married and
then you get married to somebody legally
and then you decide later that you don't
want to be married to them then you're
then you're [__]
and there's no way to bring up a [__]
prenup without the other person going
like so just exactly what are you
thinking of tapping out
believe me
um all right princess or just a lady
all right what do we got here
uh Bill I'm a sweet guy so hang
so hang out with this girl what
Bill I'm a sweet guy so when I hang out
with this girl I often try to be nice
towards her either with compliments or
little acts for example sometimes when
we're just watching a movie I'll look at
her until she sees me staring and then
say she looks beautiful yeah I'm sure
that's not creepy at all you may be
gagging right now but hey go [__]
yourself I care about her the problem is
not that
problem is not that she loves when I do
that the problem is my gift giving a few
times now I've walked off campus a short
way to pick up her favorite dish from
her favorite restaurant the first time
was because she was busy with homework
and missed dinner so I wanted to
surprise her and the other was when we
were going to hang out around lunchtime
in her dorm I got us both something I
gotta suppose something then I've also
gone to the store when she told me one
night how she wishes how she wished she
had this one type of cereal oh Jesus gee
I wish I had this one type of cereal and
then you go [__] running down the
street like
[__] Mr mcfeely
Speedy mcfeely uh how she need uh some
type of cereal and how she needed to go
to the store for milk and coffee creamer
well I've only spent like thirty dollars
total on her over the past month my
friends worn me it's either going to get
excessive or
lose its Special Touch I wonder if
that's true and what should I do Bill
thanks and have a great day uh just
kidding go [__] yourself
P.S she's not a manipulative [__] she's
gotten actually upset that I went all
out of my way to get her these things
and she told me how she feels very
grateful but kind of bad about it
um all right well first of all I didn't
say I would never say that she was a
[__] I don't know her but all women are
unbelievably manipulative they have to
be because they can't physically beat
the [__] out of US unless they're like
you know
taking that UFC [__] then that's just
game set and match because they could
already beat you mentally women can
always beat a guy mentally because they
[__] work on that that's all they
work on you know what I mean they're
like a boxer you know standing up just
throwing punches as a guy you got to
learn how to fight you got to do all
this other [__] [__] you just become
a jack of all trades master or not
okay so they [__] do that mental [__]
their entire goddamn life and then they
go down to a dojo
like can you imagine trying to [__]
debate a point with with Ronda Rousey
how far how many on how many levels it
would be [__] over as a guy
she could beat you mentally because
she's a woman so she's gonna be [__]
she's just gonna weigh you down it's
gonna be over or if she decides or you
decide to say something stupid to her
she could then beat the [__] out of you
so I mean I don't know I don't know what
you say there that's like the ultimate
[__] debate I would say
as a guy trying to beat a woman in an
argument that also holds a UFC belt
oh my God
Jesus Christ how many times would you
have to get your [__] ass kicked
mentally and physically before you even
find a weakness and that would just be
[__] brutal anyways going back to
this uh
first of all dude I don't know what the
[__] you're doing here
you should never hang out with a girl
that you like
all right you got to get it on some sort
of let's I want to take you out to
you're going to ask this [__] woman
out
you're just gonna stare at her and just
say she looks beautiful and then run
down the street and get her some food
that's not going to get you where you
want to be
okay
um
you've been hanging for a month
you're acting like her personal Butler
and she hasn't said anything like she
wants to [__]
get with you I mean I don't know I think
I feel like the window of opportunity is
closing
because pretty soon it's going to be
weird if you [__] ask her out
um I don't want to crush your dreams
here
I didn't know what your question is it
says princess or just a lady
what did you say uh well I do all do I
think it's going to be excessive yeah I
think you're going to be she's either
gonna use you which you said she's not
like that or I think you're just going
to become annoying or she's just going
to treat you as a friend and women don't
have a problem looking at you just as
like a friend so then when someday you
go to ask her out or try to kiss her or
something you're really going to weird
her out and the whole thing's gonna get
[__] up so
um
I don't know you know at some point when
she goes you know I wish I had some
cereal it's like well you know there's a
24-hour store down the street
why don't you give me some Cocoa Puffs
while you're at it and you know
something as rude as that sounds for
some reason
I don't know they respect it on some
level that you like
I don't know most women they just don't
want some guy that's just like oh my God
you're beautiful can I buy you stuff as
much as they think they want that they
just they just look at you like you're
pathetic
probably because they know on some level
that they're [__] in the head and the
fact that you can't see it you don't see
any flaws they just
they look at you like this guy's got
these just because judgment stinks
this is the guy that I'm gonna attach my
[__] wagon to somebody with no
goddamn judgment who can't read people
and like somehow he's going to bring
home the bacon
fry it up in the [__] pan I don't
think he's gonna do it so what I would
say dude is uh yeah I stopped being her
food [__]
all right she wants cereal she should go
get her to [__] itself and um
I almost think you need to back it off
and then you got to lay it on the line
that's what you got to do
back off stop buying your [__] stop
[__] hanging out with me when you run
into it just say listen
what's the deal with this okay because I
don't want to just be friends I like you
I would like to take you out and I would
like to date you that's what that's the
direction I want to go on
all right I don't want to [__] hang
out with you and go buy you s'mores
even though that's what the [__] I was
doing that's the old me this is the new
me you see me right now look at me grab
my dick right now okay because it's mine
would you care for some you know just
something like that
sorry all right Dollar Shave Club
everybody
can someone please tell me when razors
got so goddamn expensive huh what is the
deal people have I been asleep for 20
years
I was in the store the other day one
pack of razors cost 20 bucks one pack
that is insane but hey sometimes when
you buy those raises you also get a free
you also get a free gift
which is actually a punch in the dick
all right don't get beat up with
ridiculous razor prices get your shave
gear where I get mine go to
dollarshaveclub.com everybody for a few
bucks a month dollarshaveclub.com
delivers amazing razors and other great
grooming supplies like Dr cavies easy
shave butter
um right to my doorstep their plan
starts at just three dollars a month
here's how it works
they send me they sent me the handle for
free and every month they sent me
replacement blades it's one less thing
to worry about you can get deliveries
every month or every other month they've
got lots of grooming supplies too you
know that I love the one white chalies
I've never used them I just think it's
[__] hilarious
and I love you know
I almost said I love this [__] talking
of one white Charlie's really
I gotta try some of those
just [__] you know
that's disgusting that you guys just
said envisioned me trying some of those
like taking a test like I'll take a [__]
with a lab coat on and then just go one
one white right God damn it they did it
uh Why Pay twenty dollars for a Razor
when you can get a fantastic shave from
dollarshaveclub.com for a fraction of
the price stop getting smacked around by
high razor prices dollarshaveclub.com
razors are great and they are a fraction
of the price trust me
you wish that you had done it sooner
don't be a dumbass shave smarter go to
dollarshaveclub.com
all right lastly but certainly not
leastly oh I got two more here the
National Academy of sports medicine
they're here New Year's resolutions
everyone's got one get in shape be
healthy or get a new job
become a certified personal trainer with
the National Academy of sports medicine
and you can do all three the fitness
industry is booming and the demand for
personal trainers is soaring imagine
waking up every day excited to get to
work not to a job but a rewarding career
getting paid to stay in shape while
helping others uh reach their fitness
goals you'll set your own hours work in
health clubs Sports clinics and
corporate wellness and you'll love who
you work with finally do what you truly
enjoy and get paid for get a head start
on 2015 and begin your certification
with the National Academy of sports
medicine now if you don't land a job as
a personal trainer within 60 days of
certification they'll give you your
money back guaranteed go to
myusatrainer.com for free
excuse me for a free 14-day sneak peek
of their fast and fun online program
that's
myusstrainer.comer.com restrictions
apply visit my usatrainer.com for
details
legalzoom.com everybody
uh what's your New Year's resolution
Jesus Christ we're doing this again
if you're like me it's getting your life
organized stop speaking for me my New
Year's resolution is to stop losing my
[__]
okay legalism
anyways but I'm sure somebody says to
get organized where do you begin a great
place to start is protecting your family
and a great way to take control of your
family's future is with a will or living
trust that's where Legal Zoom can help
there's no easier way to get to make
sure your family is legally taken care
of getting your life organized also
means taking control of your financial
affairs so if you're thinking of
starting a business or if you already
have one legalism can help you form your
business and provide the support you
need to run it successfully for more
than 10 years LegalZoom has helped
millions of people get personalized get
personalized attention that they need
and if you'd like more help
they can connect you with an independent
attorney in most States but they are not
a law firm this month you can save even
more by entering Burr Burr in the
referral box at checkout that's promo
code Burr b-u-r-r don't let another year
pass uh pass you by before getting your
life organized for legal help you can
count on your that you can count on for
your family or small business go to
legalzoom.com promo code Burr b-u-r-r
all right there you go mercifully the
advertising is done for the [__] day
um what do we got left here
I think I read God damn it I read all
the [__] questions for the week right
at 59 look at that
um once again congratulations to the New
England Patriots that's the podcast for
this week
uh you know beyond being a fan I'm
really happy for uh Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick uh
Gronk to get his first one
the defense and all those guys to get
their [__] Rings it's just it's just
awesome and uh you know who's kid new if
Tom lost this [__] one
then he'd be three and three and all the
[__] jerk offs would be saying a
bunch of [__] about him and to be honest
this is six Super Bowls in a row this
guy drove from behind for the winning
[__] touchdown it ain't his fault
well actually no I can't say that the
last one that throw to welcome I don't
know I don't know who to blame on that
one but
um five out of six this guy's always
doing the [__] Deeds so it's so
psyched that the defense finally stepped
up and I don't even know the name of the
guy that picked off the ball I never
even [__] heard of him I read his
name I had no idea so
um anyways my apology to the sports fans
that listen to this [__] podcast
because uh
I did not see the goddamn game I can't
[__] believe it um but anyways I'm
looking forward to my time down here
in New Zealand I'm working Auckland
tomorrow night and I'm working uh
Wellington
I go
then I go to [__] southeast Asia man
can you [__] believe that I'm gonna
be going to Asia and
I already had an amazing interview
as far as like just talking to this guy
from Hong Kong
and I'm really looking forward to
meeting comics in Singapore Hong Kong
and India just to hear they'll
you know because the scenes are so new
over there and that type of stuff it's
[__] ridiculous you know I did a
podcast this week
out of India these guys two guys called
me up right [__] hilarious guy I
think India is going to be [__]
hilarious because
Indian people seem like my favorite kind
of comic where I might nothing I like
better than somebody who's really smart
but they're [__] silly and these guys
in this podcast will like that as they
tried to trick me to get in talking
about the [__] government
um
when they didn't have the [__] balls
to or whatever they weren't going to do
it they tried to get me in trouble over
there man it's [__] hilarious when I
called them out on it they [__]
laughed their asses off it was like
it was like talking to [__] Rich
bosses some [__] from uh
over there man that same kind of ball
busting so I'm just really looking
forward to uh
to that I think it's going to be
life-changing and uh and then once again
when I after I'm done with this
this Whirlwind tour here I fly from
India over to Dubai connect in Dubai and
then I go to New York so I will
literally have flown around the world
which is an unbelievable uh
privilege to be able to do that so I
really want to take the time to thank
everybody who sent me emails telling me
to come over to these places because uh
it's definitely a life-changing
experience and
um you know I ran into a bunch of Indian
Comics at the Laugh Factory maybe like
four years ago or something three years
ago I can't even tell at this point and
they actually you know knew what might
knew my stuff and said that there was
people over there that would come see
the show and that's all I need to say
and I'll [__]
figure out a way to get over there and I
actually
when I did that podcast like they were
talking about
you know
they asked me about the Philly thing
when I got booed
I was like you [__] guys saw that
over there they're like yeah you know we
do comedy you know we [__] watch the
[__] so it's uh pretty humbling man so
I'm looking forward to it gonna get some
dumplings in Hong Kong I'm gonna get
some [__] you know what's funny I'm
gonna ask the people in India
where should I go eat and I was just
thinking they're probably sick of Indian
food you know they're probably going to
take me to a sushi joint or something
like that because
you know I want to go over there and get
some [__] the best Indian food I ever
had so hopefully that's where they're
going to take me but uh
I'm really looking forward to it you
know a lot more shows to do a lot more
whiskey to drink and uh dude do you know
they don't [__] have any cigar bars
in Australia
that's what this [__] guy told me
and when you go to buy the Cuban cigars
I made a video I gotta show you this
like how [__] hardcore they are
I bought a Cuban cigar and I had to sit
outside like a [__] animal smoking
this thing outside
like I smoked a cigar the way Paul verzi
smokes a cigar standing out in the
street next to a trash can
hahaha
um anyways I don't know what to tell you
uh thanks for listening to the podcast
that's it congratulations to the
Patriots and seriously I'm not joking
condolences to the Seattle Seahawk fans
I know what the [__] that feels like
to uh have a crushing goddamn defeat but
uh you'll be back next year you know you
got a [__] great team and [__]
organization and I don't give a [__]
that your stadium makes you louder and
that some of your players did roid's I
don't give a [__] about that [__]
because everybody's [__] doing that
[__] all right